are you gonna behave yourself
No
you are my white mask Capri that power
it makes me super fast
whatever
this is awesome
we
our fandom
inside me he that power it's not
completely awful
how are you doing Eddie
oh I have a parasite
[Music]
we cannot
venom October 5th
we cannot just eat people when I see it
[Music]
is there something you want to tell him
No
get to my eyes but walk away and you
just might survive how are you doing
Eddie
you look terrible oh say venom mr. Drake
what about the allegations that your
tests and killing people finished well I
think we opened him up I'm the reporter
I found something really bad and I have
been taking
Oh operate and you just might survive
why would we do that
aren't you ready bride
I used to me October 5th
I'm a debride I'm a reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something that the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
I'm feeling really sick
who said that I have been
we'll find out October fit
you